Welcome to Mission Walkthrough. So this is NOAA Parana. This is where you can set up a bunch
of different missions that the kids that will link directly to the device. And from the device,
it will become part of what the pet asked the kids to do. And we will go through the mission page.
So this is the mission page. As you can see here on the top is different date and the list of
mission that appear on different date. So as you scroll down, there are going to be two
kind of missions. One is set at a time. So this is typically the kind of missions that
go for your routine of the day. So it's work almost like an alarm clock, right? So you
have brushed every tooth, that would be like one of the missions in the morning. Homework
first, that would be before any play or screen time, you have to do it. So you can set up
right after school, they will have to do homework before they do, they can get to do
anything charge duty something similar as well you can actually set it up all
into the missions list and this is one of the duty that the kids will have to do
for example bedtime brush so these are set at the time so let's go into set at
the time how do we do that I click on add missions and from admission I can
click on all from all I see routine so it filter out and routine let's say my
kids is still in kindergarten so these are all the list of the templates that
that we give for kindergarten kids.
So there's magic words, there's wave goodbye,
there's kind hello, thank you missions, story time.
So a lot of these are our template.
Well, you can actually create your own as well.
But before we go into that,
I can click on one of the missions
so you can see through the details.
Morning toothbrush is good morning,
it's toothbrush time, grab your toothbrush
and brush your grown up.
The top teeth with your grown up.
The top teeth and the bottom teeth,
press the button when you're all done.
So this is one of the missions
in which is almost like an alarm clock for the kids
When they see it, they say oh, it's time to do it and when they do it
They know that they will be rewarded a certain amount of gems. So you see the difficulty here. I set as
400 gems
Schedules today. I can click on it. I can set the schedule. I can set the time for example specific time
This one is brushing teeth
So it may should be it 30 a.m. Or 7 30 a.m. Click enter
Is it repeatable? Is it repeat every day? Is it repeat weekly?
Or is it monthly?
Monthly, all of this can be set over here by save schedule and go out
It will appear on the list of missions brush every tooth
So that's one of the missions that you can see here. The second part is anytime
So anytime are essentially missions that appear or in the list in which the kids know
They should do because it's part of the game and if they do it
they will be able to add more XP to the pet,
and so the pet can then evolve and grow,
become healthy, and evolve into cool forms.
So that's the encouragement for the kids
to do these kind of missions.
So under these missions, as you can see here,
if you click on one of the missions,
it's called How Does She Feel?
But what is that mission entitled?
Again, if you click on all, you'll see different pillar.
So we have emotional competence,
EQ missions and also executive functions, EF missions.
So let's go through EQ mission first.
So when EQ mission, again,
there are different type of missions of EQ missions
depending on the age range.
Right now we have preschool, we have kindergarten,
and then we have elementary.
So each of this will actually have
the upgraded level based on their age.
So let's say if I go kindergarten,
these are all the list of the template that we have.
These are all the missions in which we have worked with our border advisor to ensure that the mission list is correct and
Fit with the age appropriate. So you click on push by you'll see that
This is a content description and how does it work out the completion type you click on this
The how your child mark mission has finished either he can press the button or he can response
Using the record voice and review by parents
So you can actually use, you know, you are the one who will review it or you can have the system of NOAA
Automatically reviews and analyze the mission description to confirm
So is it a quick win if it's quick win? It's only 200 gems or is it a
You know mid-sized mission or is it a big mission?
So if it's a big mission you can give up to 600 gems
You can schedule it again, and then you can click add so here is it will appear over here as one of the missions
so you can do the same thing with EF so EF as you can see here the mission will
be a little more fun let's play the opposite word game speed level the rule
simple but the words come fast when I say up you say down and when I say down
you say up ready and then the first word is the second word is so this will
appear let's say if I already add oh I already have another EF mission here so
we can review at the apps as you can see here there's a trash duty missions that
we have to do over here so it's time so I can basically when when is the right
time it will pop up like a alarm clock so a clay start and the mission will be
played. So the kids will then go and do it and once he's done he can come back
and say, I've done it. And of course, well, this is one of the missions that required the review
of the parents. So the parents will be the one who actually approve whether or not the mission
is done in the app. That only through that, then the pet will get the gems that he need. So right
now he doesn't really have anything yet. But let's say with other missions, let's do missions where
new toy of a friend which is probably an eq mission I feel a little sad and
maybe a little envy maybe do you think I can try to play with you so that's one
of the missions of eq that we've done as you can see once it's done we'll click on it you know some
of this as missions is done and it will be updated so that's how the missions work between the apps
and also the device so